we've seen a lot of gadgets at CES this
year for the one that everybody's
talking about is the palm pre start by
me so this is a phone that was designed
by poem and it's got all these cool sort
of a applications on so its first of all
it's a touchscreen has multitouch on it
like your iPhone but unlike your iPhone
it also has a qwerty keypad and that's
we're entering data and texting and
things like that all the applications
are web-based so it talks to your like
your google calendar and talks your
entourage calendar and what it does is
it pulls all that data and coalesce is
it into one solid calendar that lives on
the phone basically it's designed to
simplify all the information that you
have out there on the internet and puts
it all in one device okay so this phone
is webOS based and all the applications
are represented by these things called
cars and what they are are just
basically little representations of
every application that you have on the
phone and you use scroll through via
touch and select on them when we want to
bring one up and it's it's just a great
easy sort of simple way to organize all
the applications that you have on the
phone another cool application for this
phone is an accessory that you can buy
for and that's called a touchstone and
basically what it is this little
magnetic black disc and you place the
phone on it and it charges it without
wires charge the phone up automatically
palm hasn't announced pricing for the
pre yet but it will be available in the
first half of 2009 and it will be
available exclusively through the sprint
network
you